i've been asked to say a few words to
the truckers in ottawa
and so i've given that some careful
consideration
all you protesters
you've accomplished an awful lot already
you know the conservative leadership has
crumbled and
aaron o'toole's been replaced by someone
who is giving a fair bit of voice to
your concerns
you now have a voice in the house of
commons all the people you represent
have a voice in the house of commons
you have four provinces that have moved
quite precipitously
in the direction that the protest was
hoping for starting to lift mass
mandates on something approximating as
reasonable a timeline as might be
expected under the circumstances
you're now faced with a difficult choice
which is
what are your criteria for satisfaction
you need to determine that and so that
you can negotiate with the necessary
people
you're also faced with the danger at the
moment now which is that as
the political process bends in the
direction that you've insisted upon so
rightly in my estimation
more and more of you who are most
reasonable are going to pack up and
leave or decide that this is done
sometime over the next week or so or a
couple of weeks that's obviously up to
you but there'll be a remnant that's
much more committed in some sense to
more extreme goals and that's going to
be something very difficult to manage
um i'd like to commend all of you for
your diligence and
and work on accomplishing what you have
accomplished under
under trying conditions and also
for keeping your heads in a way that's
actually being
a
model for the entire world the fact that
you've been able to remain peaceful you
haven't taken the bait you haven't
responded with violence to
quite remarkable denigration and
provocation that's
a sign of tremendous discipline and care
it's going to get more difficult to
maintain as this goes along
so i hope that you're all in this
position to
allow
a sufficient victory to be sufficient
to move forward without groundcore
to
be
grateful for the effect that you've
already had in the support that you've
received
and to
move forward to a normative peace and
the re-establishment of our
country's economy and our
psychological and social well-being
so
that's pretty much all i have to say at
this point
thank you